dumb advice number four listen just keep  trying don't worry about it it's all  right just keep trying eventually it's  gonna work out for you wrong advice  because if i keep doing something the  wrong way over and over and over again  i'm still gonna get bad results if you  tend to have bad relationships one two  three four five six and you keep doing  the same things there's something wrong  with your habit or your trend so you  don't just keep trying you take a step  back  you try to go study the approach and you  ask somebody else what they think about  your approach that they're getting  results you try to study it and maybe  you keep adjusting and making pivots and  then you try a new way so maybe it ought  to be just keep trying new ways until  you get the results rather than just  keep trying